ce garçon tout stressé va donc épouser
ma soeur aimée sérieux poteau tu es
vraiment vilain qu'est ce tu fous avec
ace virk la caméra les gaffes
c'est à mon grand père il a filmé le
mariage de mes parents avec sa part
turpitudes la tradition et semoy faire
du slam à la cérémonie mais c'était déjà
dit non c'est poétique non mais t'es un
témoin fait des trucs de témoin enfin je
sais pas ce qu'ils font mais les témoins
ne slam pas est ce parce que t'as pas
compris que ça va être un interlude
poétique où ce film je me lève en pleine
cérémonie les gens résistent tiens on va
faire un discours ça va être chiant
comme d'hab la sors mon portable quoi
qu'est ce qui se passe et la ban
on est ici pour célébrer l'union de deux
personnes que j'aime ce n'est rien de
serviles quand il s'agit de servir un
frérot pas de problème les gens veulent
s'en vient c'est ce point qui a donné le
ballon cinq sens bien je suis désolé je
peux plus je fais plus je peux plus quoi
faire un truc tout ce mariage c'est
rouge arrive pas je peux plus à
t'entendre dire quoi là je suis en train
de dire qu'on se marie par une arête je
peux plus c'est trop pour moi j'arrive
pas mais tu me dit d'attendre tu viens
tu me dis le jour non mais oui bien sûr
super je suis pas censé ne pas devoir
robe de mariée il ya des traditions
faisons ça fait en sorte que isa et ma
mère soit pas toi te plaît bizarre lisa
ma tante vient montrer tu crois que je
connais tous les boss de ta famille quoi
à présent ça n est pas beau flynn genre
comme on traite mais elle est fan et je
suis tellement fière de toi ça mais
comment ça se fait que tu es aussi
d'étendre sa phase jamais vu ça ils
disent que quand tu es stressé de haut
qui fait genre tu rigole t détente et ou
alors au fond ça y est à leroy des
théories fois russes commencent à
s'exprimer non non mais la patte en
attend c'est quand même le plus beau
jour de ta vie tes limites en mode pause
café quoi je bande non pas du tout non
j'aborde mon mariage à l'image de votre
coupé avec meilleure cure tu vois genre
cool
détente très amoureux aussi tu vois bon
c'est pas le plus beau jour de ma vie
mais ça fera forcément partie d'un des
plus beaux jours de ma vie alors je vois
ce que veut dire le jour je me mariais
parce que ça va arriver
ok elle sera pas le plus beau jour de ma
vie est loin de là même pas le deuxième
même pas le troisième en vrai j'étais là
en direct à la télé quand beaucoup il se
transforme en serial j'étais temps
j'étais là avant toi tu classes les plus
beaux jours et à vivre ouais ok et donc
du coup c'est quoi le plus beau le
retail pour ce genre le top 2 pape
s'oppose au pop
j'étais prêt à défoncer la ville
savourer jusqu'au jour de ta vie ouais
mais quand j'ai fait un rêve c'était le
plus beau tapis ce sacre est toujours ta
vraie vie pas lepéniste avis ok mais
quand j'ai fait le rêve c'était en plein
jour après le déjeuner donc ça peut
compter comme un jour donc ça peut quand
même beau jour de ma vie parce qu'ils
apprennent à moustache qu'on admire
deuxième ronde
oui enfin bon c'est un duvet c'est pas
là vous vous prenez pour le comité de
validation des plus beaux jours dans la
ville de lons normal vous parlez de quoi
le minus c'est lui qui raconte n'importe
quoi depuis tout à l'heure où ce toi
t'es show notre travail - ouais ouais je
suis en train de me dire tu vaut ne pas
ça fait peut-être too much la toile et à
semelle plus beau jour de ta vie alors
c'est vrai que déjà elle n'est pas finie
fini m'a dit mais je pense que le plus
beau jour de ma vie ce serait
attendez ça on va les tester à 10
minutes qui vit son plus beau jour il ya
10 min c'est normal c'est ma meilleure
pote matin mais elle est éclatée ton
plus beau jour de ta vie il est calqué
sur ce qu'ils sont c'est ton plus beau
jour à elle un nouveau jour de ta vie
par procuration
ok madame j'ai un vieux plus beaux jours
de ma life et voilà tu es tout frais
mais c'est cool mais la vie ans plus
tard adorent abba il est plus tendue que
toi ok ce qui t'arrive député retard a
pas de me parler comme si j'en avais
rien à [ __ ] de mon match démarre pas
je vous pose la question c'est tout moi
je pensais qu'aujourd'hui serait le plus
beau jour de ta vie ah oui et pourquoi
cette part est logique que ce soit plus
beau jour de ma vie c'est parce que je
suis une femme c'est donc le match est
censé être le plus beau jour de mai et
après ce sera quoi la naissance de mon
premier coach suppose bon tout est bon
on va pouvoir y aller moi on va demander
arthur comme ça je serai prêt le grand
frère misogyne aujourd'hui c'est bien le
plus beau jour de ta vie non je crois
mon plus beau jour
c'est quand j'ai demandé en mariage
c'était ouf
e
[Musique]
what a fait sa demande par sms
et toi tu as accepté mais oui c'était
trop mignon il avait mis des hémorragies
ça a tout changé
cha j'ai pas besoin d'un beau jour de ma
vie j'avais juste plusieurs comme ça on
les voit
[Musique]
on est ici pour célébrer l'union de deux
personnes que j'aime rien de serviles
quand il s'agit de servir un frérot pas
de problème ils se sont vus ils se sont
aimés de manière instantanée
un édile qui a vu le jour il ya quelques
années
pourtant ils sont tellement bien qu'on
dirait qu'ils se connaissent depuis
qu'ils sont nés la reverso l'autre et
lyon recto verso pour ce couple digne du
roi diot nahla estime bassem jusqu'à ce
que scarlets sais pas pas de cicatrice
pour ce couple qui est maintenant mariée
j'ai nommé naïma et arthur ils vont
dénoncer la pied il monte moins il vont
démonter la pièce ronde
oui non si jamais j'arrive